as you've been seeing like in this one
right often these later properties they
kind of rest on the earlier properties
as their foundation okay so before we
get to 14 um Andi 13 just watch me do
the proofs so let's have a look this
I can't now let's look at this one this
is really quick and it's a beautifully
elegant proof and in fact it uses
something that we learnt uses a tool
that we learned from calculus this is
not 13 this is not 13 it doesn't look
like 13 anyway because 13 has to do with
a tangent and I had not drawn tangent I
have drawn off I've drawn a secant right
but a tangent is really a special kind
of secant it's a secret where the two
points where you cut the circle where
they happen to coincide where they sit
on top of one level so tangent to the
sequence if you remember back to when we
were doing first principles they're like
sort of cousins with each other so
therefore I'm going to get to 13 through
this guy I want to get this slide here
I've able T for tangent I want to become
a tangent right so therefore what I'm
going to have is I want pain to approach
Q that's I'm gonna consider this limit
as that happens I've got this angle up
in here formed at the center that's
subtended by PQ okay but I also have opq
which is our Sosthenes
you carry that okay so therefore o P Q
and o QP both being equal what are the
sizes of those angles what was the size
of each is perfect to see think about it
yeah so this is Theta so this whole
thing's gonna add up to 180 minus sorry
so I'm gonna add 180 so these two have
to add to 180 minus theta do you agree
with that but I've got to split it for
two angles yeah so what I'm getting
really is ninety degrees minus half
theta you care with that there's another
set
okay so now therefore as a approaches Q
what happens to that angle theta it's
intended at the center theater is going
to approach a value as well right it's
going to approach zero it's going to get
narrower and narrower now can you see
that can you see it in your mind's eye
sort of coming to go so theta is going
to approach zero right so as theater
approaches zero what's gonna happen to
these guys 90 minus theta or two will
approach 90 right so therefore I can say
angle P T will be oops approaches now
you see that so therefore this is what I
have this is the special case where the
two points P and Q acute P and Q they
coincide there right there and so
they're both equal to 90 degrees so
here's the picture okay all right so
it's a Marvis little privets really I
think it's quite beautiful a lot of
these circle properties can be proved in
very elegant ways and I gave you a big
clue by leading in with this guy a big
clue let's just remember what we're
trying to show read it right it's a bit
of math form the angle between a
concurrent tangent and chord pause
tangent chord right so that's where
they're concurrent okay at that point of
contact on the circumference the angle
between the concurrent engine chord by
the way you will notice there are two
there are two this is an angle between
the tangent and a chord but there's
another chord over here you see that so
there's another one I can do this either
way in fact one of the important things
that you'll be having to spot later on
is sometimes you'd like one one angle
between this tangent cord and the
alternate segment between obvious and
then you don't remember to look at the
other side which is just as useful but
this is the angle
I'm talking about right now between the
tangent of the court and what I want to
show is it's equal to the angle in the
alternate segment segment alternate
segment so there's that angle in the
alternate saver then I'm after okay so
there's two green things that's what I'm
trying to do you mean like a
quadrilateral like a thing because
there's too much as you'll see in a
second there's too many young there's
too many variables too many things you
could possibly change where is he it's
like once you draw the triangle it's
locked in all right so I gave you this
big clue right that something like this
is going to be pulled in so what I'm
gonna do is at this point of contact
I can draw I can draw a radius just like
that but I'm going to go one better and
I'm going to draw a diameter now I've
drawn it in such an orientation that
I've got potential going that way so
it's pretty easy just to run through all
the diameter and it's just gonna be
vertical at that point okay so do my
best
there we go okay so today I'm enough
it's a radius to indicate that it's a
diameter and not just some random chord
I put a big fat dot on it to indicate
the setup now I've got to get from over
here all the way around to over there
alright so how am I going to do it what
do I know I've just drawn the diamond so
it's perpendicular to this radius sorry
this teaser
you're great perpendicular so Annie I
need a bit of language here right so
what should we call this angle between
the tangent in the core ones like to
name it so I'm at alpha over here
and I have my tea over here does that
mean yeah good right nestled in there I
have 90 minus alpha by the way it's 90
degrees we will get on to the UM the
other angles in time so I've got that
angle there that's nice but what am I
gonna do with that angle okay and how is
it going to be related to this one okay
it's 90 degree field I think there's
another right angle in this diagram I
just haven't drawn a ninya right yeah
what do you say this
yep oh wait this one over here this one
over here okay you can't come over here
yeah okay so you've got you've got a
couple of different options now here's
the thing right now you can go in many
directions mark why were you gonna go in
center - we're here over here okay so I
could join this up that's going to give
me some that's gonna give me an
isosceles triangle over here you can go
there but the reason I would use the
isosceles triangle actually cuz of that
guy now this is why I drew a diameter
rather it's okay it will probably just
be a different direction to get to the
same thing at least the heart all right
okay now if I've got that angle over
there okay look carefully I have an
angle here can you tell me can you tell
me what the relationship is this one
what are those those two radiators
do you see it those two red angles are
standing on my red arm okay I can't say
so this guy is 90 degrees minus alpha
but but I know that the angle in a
semi-circle hold on there we go alpha
what's your other way so you're talking
about this one yeah so so just in case
you can catch that which is just
literally it's really funny there are so
many circle plans you can do so we're
sort of going around in circles right
but I got there I got there by using
take advantage of this 90 degrees and
this 90 degrees okay and there's that
symmetry there but the other way yo is
alright so you have a nice oscillation
triangle here that just gives you the
angle sum right and this angle is at the
center corresponding to this angle is at
the circumference standing on a drawing
for you standing on this green arc over
here
right here okay you see what we mean by
like the reason why this list is so
intimidatingly long is because of how
freakin awesome circles are and it's
like I'm just gonna randomly draw lines
and tada amazing properties just emerge
okay so this is a really important one
though I'm emphasizing it because it is
traditionally hard to spot it is easy to
spot when you're like that's the one I'm
looking for but when you have a list of
20 that are all up in your head you're
like which one is it okay um
this is this becomes a little more
challenging right so you have to spot it
um
often it's in that drawing the diagram
sometimes you need to redraw the diagram
like this is messy now let you agree
that there's all sorts of stuff um in
sometimes you have to redraw it with
less features on it so that right so
that the angle in the alternate segment
becomes more obvious when there is less
stuff there okay so constructions solve
problems but they also introduce
problems they make things hard to see
okay